mitch is in kansas city mitch is
how can we help sir hey dave uh
thanks for taking my call sure um i am
28 i'm single i have a daughter who
lives with her mother
um i'm currently renting i make about
50k a year
growth i'm on baby step two and my uh
my question is my credit karma shows
that i have about eight accounts and
collections
with around twenty four hundred dollars
owed which is relatively easy to take
care of
i guess and i can pay that off within
three to four months or so
the problem is that i have um you know
i'm 100
positive that credit card isn't showing
me my entire debt or collections list
um how do i find that list and who
should i contact
about the correct or most efficient way
to get them removed or
entirely you know well uh to start with
credit karma's crap
okay let's just establish that so it's
it's a it's a bait-and-switch thing to
get you signed up for more debt
is it's just a mess so what
instead what i would do is let's go to
all three of the major credit bureaus
directly and pull a copy of your credit
bureau report
you can get a lot more detail that way
of exactly what is owed
and who last reported to you so these
are old enough debts that they've
probably been sold off to someone else
is what you're thinking
yeah yeah okay so you need to dig
through that and start contacting them
and it's it's a bit of a treasure hunt
because they start selling this bad debt
from
place to place to place to place how old
are these debts how long since you paid
on them
a lot of them are five years or some of
them are three but
you know yeah you've got a past okay
sure that you've grown
up through okay so yeah get in touch
with them be sure you get in
writing what you're agreeing to pay them
which might be the original balance that
they've marked up seven fold by now
but get it in writing and do not give
them electronic access to your checking
account
but just go to the three major credit
bureau reporting
companies experian transunion and
equifax
and you can pull out what you need there
directly and you'll get much
higher quality of information because
they're not trying to bait and switch
as much